And you can't have a birthday without puppies.
(audience cheers)
Yep.
And back stage are some furry friends
who are actually up for adoption.
Awww.
That's right, where are Kyler, Tucker,
and Lindsay Poochaw?
Oh, hi ladies, come on up.
(audience cheers)
You know, I was just thinking,
I heard that maybe, just maybe,
you guys are open to possible adoption.
Oh yeah, most definitely.
Moved here from Kankakee, Illinois,
so it would be nice to start, you know, a family,
and get a little guy or girl.
And are you possibly open to adoption?
Yeah, we're looking to get a dog
as soon as we can, so.
Okay, so, let me...
This is...
Aww.
This is Besus.
Ooh.
Yep.
And this is Ramona.
(audience laughs)
(audience cheers)
You know, you guys,
you just go ahead back stage and bond
and you know, we'll check in with you.
No pressure.
Great, thank you.
Thank you so much for coming, you guys!
(audience cheers)
Thank you, thank you.
(upbeat music)